forza ragazzi bentornati su benetton
rugby che mangiano dove devi spaccare la
faccia tutti quanti infatti una
maglietta adeguata ma è uscita è uscita
errata l'hanno fatta i players c'è la
modalità scp di questo gioco hanno fatto
l'ala salve ma chi è questo hanno fatto
a mano dei testi cp cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che hanno fatto il containment
bridge significa che c'è questo
laboratorio segreto bruciarli scp però
non ci siano veramente belli gli sc p ma
l'obiettivo è sempre quello di spaccare
il culo a tutti
allora fernando non so se ne sia accorto
però c'è una chiave qua per terra la
vedi questa noi apprendiamo questa
chiave la prendi 26 parlando vieni qui
vieni qua prendi prendi quel coltello
che ce la fa sotto ci serve
tieni fernando è tuo fernando è tuo
prendi lo abbiamo la chiave possiamo
uscire usciamo non so quanto sia sicuro
visto del containment bridge è pieno di
mostri però ci proviamo
non mi attacca non fa niente finché non
attacco io per primo questa la
caratteristica il numero uno del gioco
finché non attacchi tu per primo non
nessuno ha poi aprire anche la thriller
forte venite ragazzi tutti qua e cioè
queste parti
non mi picchiate subito ragazzi state
picchiando una porta che non la sta
prendendo proprio bene ma poveri poveri
va dai scuole non ho fatto niente io non
ho fatto niente ragazzi aiuto difende
temi io non ho fatto niente
bravo prende a cazzotti le porte non ho
capito perché c'erano con le porti il
posto per arrivare celant insomma hai
colpito il tuo compagni idiota mori e
ucciso ucciso
abbiamo fatto sono morti
la rivolta ha avuto successo togliti
faccio io faccio io ce l'ho fatta ce
l'ho fatta perfetto by now prendo anche
la antisommossa ma che bravo allora
ragazzi abbiamo sbloccato il corridoio è
il momento per adesso son diventati un
fenice questi lamentele che picchia lo
picchia gli scp madonna sarà un casino
che date mille taser di prima per favore
eccolo il design dovrebbe essere non so
se gli scp in qualche modo la donna è
servito e morto tornante sera è
fortissimo recato nella madonna c'è il
tipo cam braccio disintegrato
ah no è un tempo l'ho visto bene apcom
però non capisco che se ci sono perché
ognuno c'è il suo nome non esserci più
giovanni scp non c'è bisogno della
tessera blu addirittura non ce lo
avessero botanico amico amico era giusto
faccio io non ti preoccupare ma certo è
strano perfetto aprono le porte don't
worry vedi che sono dietro il muro
perché vedono che già c'è qualche npc
dietro il muro sono che dovreste fare il
giro ragazzi che è successo
entro io son lì beh siete entrati prima
voglio posso entrare anche io no un
fucile c'è anche un taser qua è pieno di
roba ragazze utile faccio strada io
seguitemi minchiate botta minchia che
voltano vernici rimanente sezione
87 qualcosa mi dice che suscita un
gigante ci farà un culo quadro 65
minchia ragazzi sono un fenomeno oggi
che mi è successo
ok venisse sto facendo tutto io
tranquilli 4 porca h3 molto subito 29
luglio a noi altri due sole siete voi
ragazzi siete voi ne manca uno perfetto
perfetto ho vinto e quindi è corto
peccato mi stavo divertendo un sacco
penso ce ne fossero molti di più porca
vacca quindi ho finito vinto questa
l'uscita con la macchina proprio a lui
era carino perché tutto è un po corta
dai farne un altro che è family friendly
cioè non puoi mettere non fedeli fendi è
un gioco a cubetti da ragazzi cedere una
sorta di minecraft con sangue ciao
siamo su un treno mi ricorda il film
come si chiama snow perche credo che sia
sono perse piercer come cacchio iamm
salve queste di cuochi del treno
problema
datevi un arma in tutto sto casino
eccola qui perfetto quindi io devo
menarmi tutti salve questo poi fabrizio
chiaramente fabrizio cessi
ma no non voglio staccare lavandino
porca vacca salve
era una madonna che succede cosa ci fa
qua richards htt torno
sto cercando o eccola la chiave madonna
cosa sto vedendo quante armi
porca vacca c'era la polizia ha capito
me non ho fatto niente solo perché sono
entrato nella porta mi date una mano voi
tutti la polizia che li filava il
momento di diventare
chuck norris mamma e uno atti prossimo
ai a chiamare fame due rose venuti fuori
alle pale ucciso ucciso era la fabula
solito perfetto scusate i ragazzi devo
picchiarli per forza perché sono stato
qua tutto il giorno bello però
l'obiettivo credo che sia quello di
farli cadere tutti penso sia il modo più
efficace per fare per i due però ogni
volta che lei
era tutto calcolato ovviamente ci siete
ok
auguri grazie del bicchiere dovrei usare
un altro shockwave e teoricamente ma per
usarlo devo prima a tirare tutti questi
di fori che il modo migliore per
spazzare alla fine lo choc e la cosa
migliore
buongiorno tu mi sei sul culo perfetto
appena venite da questa parte a si
picchiano che tra di loro mi sa di no
ragazzi dovete porca vacca del casinò
dovete venire da me sennò non riesco a
farli fuori tutti venisse davvero che io
sentii cuori più quasi tutti senza usare
lo sciocco e c'e veramente
ma la smettete di menardi tra di voi
venite da me porca vacca armi qua sopra
se niente di veramente in tv per favore
porca vacca giusto pieno di gente che
vuole picchiarmi che cacchio tutto a
posto
sono sceso venite qua combatteteli qua
per favore che combattono tra di loro
stile menti maori berserk re di quel
berserk e teoricamente dovrei riuscire a
fare qualcosa di decente perché è sempre
abbastanza utile il terzo di più però
dovete quanti ne sono rimasti perché non
ne sono convinto
che peccato che ho fatto fuori quasi
tutti chi diavolo rimasto lega c'è uno
col passo il rookie ato là dentro
123 mori col bicchiere bicchierate in
faccia lega veramente utili perfetto gli
capiti capi treno posso provare a far
così niente mancato zio aspetta c'è una
barriera invalicabile la madonna che
volta bilancio il cibo i piatti chiedevo
cavalcata il re medico perchè alla fine
non erano così tanti perfetto mentre man
in due la tu chi sei
da dove vieni mori perfetto a quella di
lanciare cibo basta 7 remaining devo
andare dall'altra parte perché c'è la
polizia sicuro però non ho non ho modo
di anno specie se ancora questi che si
menano faccio io ragazzi tranquilli
visto risparmiando un sacco di tempo
porca vacca ho rischiato menate di voi
due ragazzi io trovo una cosa chiara
perfetto aiuto ma lei non è l'alto diate
in faccia benissimo manca solo la
polizia ragazzi che dietro sta roba cava
come no hanno aspetta forse devo vera
chiave dove la chiave
la chiave era dai capi staziona donna
impossibile però fare tutto il giro ci
sono se non mi dicono
eccola qua nicchia non mi ricordavo c'è
un piccone gigantesco però mi sa che uso
il potere perché credo che il berserk in
questo caso sia un attimo indicato poi
magari mi sbaglio allora vediamo open
madonna bears e pugni in faccia
minchia che male minchia che male di chi
sa che male l'ho fatta e rimasto è
rimasto solo questo un mazzo fortissimo
2 mercato allora morto perché amazing
hai finito zio basta basta
e finito fido ma gotto di exit and leave
del quale l'exit mi mancavano averi che
poi scavalcare il suo posto pieni
lingotti oh mio dio cosa sta
trasportando stato bravo poi rischiato
tantissimo perché sono quasi morto e non
è ancora detto potrei chiedere da qua
però ragazzi non ho idea di dove
dovrebbe essere riuscita anche perché
non c'è una porta ma non c'è è questa
luce nadal davanti e scuola davanti
nuova beh è un senso per ok signori
questo era predetta un red scpa e treno
molto figo un casino atroce però molto
figo non disturbare la gente sul treno
questa è la morale c'è sempre una morale
impedite da un red troviamo la sempre
perché è importante ci vediamo ragazze
di un prossimo episodio fatemi sapere se
volete un altro perché non hanno senso
se i livelli cui mi divertono sempre di
sky dedica ai ragazzi schiaccia il tasto
mi piace e noi come sempre ci vediamo ad
un prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]